hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game between international
master la sales table avec also known as
I am Lola Sun Li chess and everyone's
favorite artificial intelligence these
days lela lela chests zero zero in her
name stands for no human interference as
no humans interfered in in her learning
process so everything she knows about
chess she taught herself some of you
might object to me referring to her as a
she
maybe I should refer to her as an it but
I mean makes really no difference
I just makes it easier they chose a they
chose a woman's name so might as well
refer to her as a she but I mean that's
really not relevant here is it it's the
the way if she plays chess and that
that's what we all want to see so I
chose this game not only because it's
against the French but also because it's
a very nice game where once again Lila
chooses a very human approach and in
dealing with this game so let's see the
game this game believer has the white
pieces and here she opens with E for so
II 6 we have the French defense d4 d5
Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 so once
again the V number variation we had be 5
advanced variation and you might
remember from my yesterday's video that
a nice game from 1995 between Garry
Kasparov and vastly von Schuch given
Chuck went b6 here and after the
standard a 3:1 Chuck went this a very
very powerful idea of Bishop to f8 but
in this game we have the standard line
in knife to b7
now again a3 and Bishop captures on c3
the captors on c3 and c5 so the
variation in my previous video I said
that this is like something you will
encounter most often and here at Bishop
to d3 another weight another way this
will be played as Queen to g4 where
black can usually give up give up the g7
pawn but here Lilla goes Bishop to d3 we
have Knight B to c6 which is definitely
the precise idea you don't want to play
something like C
ceefor seems like an interesting
decision because you will maybe put a
push whites Bishop the back I special
will not be on this strong diagonal but
this is something that doesn't go with
the the basic ideas of the French
defense in in the French defense you
want to control the center and whenever
you feel like it you want to be able to
destroy the center but by walking down
the center with c4 white can even keep
his King in the center and the white
king will be perfectly saved there so
basically you're not gonna have too much
fun here so after Bishop to d3 Knight B
to c6 Queen to g4 now going for the g7
pawn and now Queen to a5 and here better
up to d2 defending the c3 pawn you don't
really have the option of going 27 with
the idea that after Queen captures with
check King d1 and now black will capture
and then you will capture here because
black we'll just play rock jet and a
laugh in your face you now have to move
the Queen and now you lose a whole rook
so this would be very unfortunate do not
do something like this
so Bishop d2 defending the c3 pawn and
here we have castles a brave move by him
lawless as both bishops and the Queen
are eyeing that I had that King side
knife to f3 bringing the knight into the
game and now we have f5 and here it
seems like a move that is really
screaming for it captures on f6 and
Poisson you don't want your Bishop not
to be eyeing the h7 pawn but Leela here
actually doesn't doesn't capture she
plays a Queen to f4 and here we have b6
again locking this in with c4 it seems
like you've done a great job with f5 you
got rid of the Queen the bishop is no
longer threat but even if you push c4
now and you force the Bishop to e2 again
you're done you're not really gonna have
much fun here as black white white can
play simple moves like maybe Queen h4 9
g5
attack h7 pressure d6 pawn so definitely
don't wanna don't want to commit to a
move like c4 so after Queen f4 b6 now
preparing to develop the life
Bishop to a6 we have castles by Lila and
now Bishop to a6 offering a trade of the
LightSquared Bishop D captures on c5 b
captures on c5 and now rook F 2 e1 rook
a to b8 assuming the open B file Queen
to h4 and now black has to make some
uncomfortable decisions here the queen
is very nicely placed on h4 year white
is definitely having ideas of Knight to
g5 would ideas of Queen to h7 and also
the night from g5 will be threatening to
capture that east 6 pawn so probably
best idea for black here would be simply
Bishop back to c8 to defend this pawn
and then Knight to g5 wouldn't really be
much of a threat as you could simply
kick it away yeah no harm no harm done
but here and you don't want to play
something like an IG 6 the trunking the
Queen away because Queen h5 and then
Knight to g5 will really be a threat
because you no longer have the option of
h6 so iam lawless goes immediately for
h6 to stop and in IG 5 IDs in the future
but this gives a little idea opportunity
to grab the h6 pawn with the bishops so
Bishop captures on h6 pawn captures and
Queen captures is it really a piece
sacrifice well she did grab two points
two very important points for the piece
so maybe it can't really be considered
the sacrifice what yeah if it was three
points for the piece then it would be
like an exchange but with two points for
the piece then maybe I think it could be
considered the sacrifice so now rook to
f7 definitely the best idea you don't
want to allow Knight to g5 with with
some terrible threats of Queen Queen h7
and again with threats of capturing on
h6 an e6 sorry about that
so here we have first Bishop captures on
a6 Queen cat person a6 and now Knight to
g5 first attacking the rook there's
always time to grab d6 pawn otherwise in
no rush to do so and here lawless played
nice to d8 which is definitely the best
move you wanna
you want to bring the night closer to
the defense and you wanna guard the e6
pawn trying to guard the rook with
something like rock to g7 would quickly
fall apart to do two Queen captures on
e6 would to check and after King to f8
back Queen back to f6 check King Jade
and now rook to e3 and here white would
have a clear clear idea of rock to h3
Queen h6 could be an idea
Queen to a trade the night is very
nicely covering both h7 and f7 so here
lawless goes 4/9 to be 8 and here we
have Knight captures on f7 Knight
captures on f7 and now Queen kept Queen
to f6 attacking the knight on e7 you
don't you don't want to play a move like
rook to e8 or something like this the
defender rook because then again rook to
e3 fall by row to jittery will be a very
powerful idea so after Queen - if Queen
to f6 King to f8 guarding the night and
also making some room for the King to
run to the Queen side if needed here we
have low K to be 1
Rock the b6 so if the rooks are
exchanged then black will improve his
pawn structure h4 now and here we see
what the real idea behind the position
is so lawless has two knights for a rock
which is definitely in favor of black
but Leela has this past H pawn and she
is not afraid to use it
we have nice to g8 attacking the Queen
Queen to g6 and the knight back to e7 so
lawless repeats the position and the
allele repeats back Queen to f6
we have Knight back to g8 again
attacking the Queen Queen to g6 and the
knight to e7 and here if Leela will
repeat once again Quinta f6 we would
have a draw by threefold repetition but
Leela is not interested in a draw as it
seems and she plays Queen to g3 so okay
Queen to c4 we have rook captures pawn
captures and now Rock the b1 attacking
the b6 pawn we have b5 now The Rock now
the point is protected by the Queen and
now h5 as you all know passed pawns must
be pushed
we have d4 seek after somebody for see
captors on d4 and now
Queen to b3 Lila offers a trade of
Queens which wasn't really favored black
but if black captures then C captures
and then a for creates now a passed pawn
all the way on the Queen side so white
would have a pest a pawn and the base
past h1 so we have a knight captures on
e5 basically a free porn why not capture
it h6 now black definitely must deal
with this pawn once again if you capture
like doesn't even have to capture with a
pawn better yet ya better leave the pond
here so so this pawn so blacks deep on
cannot start running forward so better
rook capture some b3 and after King to
g8 as you do have to attend to the past
H pawn now you will capture here and
after Knight moves then the past a pawn
will start running up the board and at
one point black will definitely have to
give give up at least one of the Knights
and then it will be a slow death for
black
so after h6 we have King to f7 and now
comes Queen captor zombie v Queen
captures and rook captures attacking the
knight on d5 we have Knight to c4 now
comes a for the pond was attacked on a3
Knight to c6 and now rook to c5
affecting both of blacks nights we have
night for to a5 and now comes g4 g for a
very powerful idea by lua
if f captures on g4 then rock to g5 you
cut off the king and then this pawn is
free to free to become a queen so after
g4 king to g6 and now we have g5 now the
past H point is protected again you can
never capture this because this guy is
then unstoppable and another thing you
can see that it's never a good idea for
both of your Knights to be protecting
each other because now if you move this
night then rock captures this night if
you move this night then rope captures
this night so luck doesn't really have a
move he can he can simply wait for for
white finish this any any way he wants
or she wants in this case so ii v we
have rocked the d5 and now preparing
rock to d6 check efore rook to
six check if you if you go to H five
then the H pawn marches forward King to
h7 group to d7 check King to g8 and we
have g 6f four black also has a couple
of points he does want to put them as
well we have h seven check King to H
eight and now rope to f7 and in this
position all of us resigned the game as
there is really no defense against rock
to f8 you could continue this maybe push
III or or you could try something for
example yeah I mean you don't really
gain anything by moving the Knights so
let's say III and then after rook checks
King moves now you get a queen and now
you have basically the theme from our
eternal board from from yesterday rook
rook f6 checking g5 q h6 checking before
and Rock Arizona 4 will be checkmate but
yeah after this I believe it was it was
a rook d7 no it was Rock f7 y after the
rail after rook f7 this was move 45 it
was in this position that Norwegian
international master lost a beloved
resigned the game so a very nice a very
nice one by Leela and I mean definitely
I mean probably we'd have to check if a
stronger engine would also capture the
pawn and h6 probably probably it would
but also it was a very interesting game
so I do hope you enjoyed it and you know
if if you always are looking for new
ideas how to tackle the French then I
hope this was a useful game for you to
to maybe even learn something from and
yeah I didn't mention this in my
previous video but if you're just tuning
in Ollila
is now also playing on leeches and this
is a photo I made in the morning so she
had 332 followers but now I believe she
has over a thousand and yeah I mean do
check out my previous video there I will
say a lot more about Leela so if you if
you're interested you can check check
some some more of her games
and follow her you know process and her
progress so I will put all of the links
in the description below to check out
all of them there will be more games
Lila played you can follow her on all of
the social networks and you can also
follow I am loveless unleashes you know
feel free to challenge him for a game as
well maybe he would be interested and
accepts it and yeah that's basically it
I would like to thank Zeeman siren and
Michael Stirling for a contribution to
my channel thank you what - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here at the top
left one will be previous game played by
Lila zero against in lawless it's Game
one of their match so do check it out as
well if you're just tuning in thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
with hopefully another interesting video
thank you